Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to let's go to
Jamie from Canada. Jamie, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, David, how are you doing?
Speaker 1: I'm doing.
Speaker 4: Well. Good. I called in a couple
of times before, and most of my questions
were hypotheticals. And I. I don't know if it's
harder to answer a hypothetical question than a
question with a factual basis in it.
Speaker 1: Well, that's that question
is in and of itself hypothetical. Let me
hear the two options and then I'll tell
you which question's more difficult.
Speaker 4: Okay. I was just wondering.
This is a hypothetical again. This is a
hypothetical. Okay. I was just wondering.
So say like Democrats get hypothetically. I'm
sorry. That's the word of the day. They they
get hypothetically, they get 52 Dems. And then
then they decided to do the rules change to like
pass that what they what Chuck tried to do back
in January failed. They hypothetically that like
mansion and cinema are like, well, we're switching
parties so that it goes back to 5050. Yes. Do you
see something like that happening? No. Okay?
Speaker 1: Yeah. No, I don't think so.
Speaker 4: Okay. Okay. And another thing
that I was just wondering was how do I talk
to my mom about abortion?
Speaker 1: Because, well,
what are you trying to do?
Speaker 4: She's Catholic,
and so she doesn't agree with that.
Speaker 1: Okay. Well, let me ask you
this. Is it is it merely an academic discussion or
is there some practical nature to the discussion?
Speaker 4: No, it's a it's a it's mostly
academic, mostly emotional. Like she says
she doesn't agree with it whatsoever. She says
she she says she doesn't agree with that on the
on the principle of it whatsoever.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm curious,
Jamie. I mean, you're in Canada and abortion is
relatively it's legal and relatively
accessible in Canada. Is that correct?
Speaker 4: Mm hmm. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So I guess my question is,
what do you want to achieve? What's the point
of fighting this fight with your mom? Is it you
just want to convince her first for some reason?
Speaker 4: Well, no, I don't want to fight with
her anymore. She thinks it's something that it
shouldn't be. And I said, Well, I'm trying to
say to her, I suppose my arguments in the past
have been very emotional forward and she doesn't
take too kindly to that. And I suppose I just
wanted just more factual way of of, of, of, of,
you know, having this conversation with her.
Speaker 1: Well, listen. To give to give you
specific ideas, we would need to go into her.
People are opposed to abortion for different
reasons. So you need to kind of meet them where
they are. And we don't have the scope to do that
here. But one thing I would just think about is,
is this really a fight you even want to have with
your mom, you know?
Speaker 4: No, no.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So maybe you
just don't convince her. You just
let her. I think what she thinks. I don't know.
Speaker 4: Yes, I know. And she's and she and
you know, it's funny. I don't know I don't know if
this is it's funny. Even though I have an argument
with her on abortion, she she votes. She votes
Green Party. Yeah. Interesting. It's interesting.
I know. And she said she said probably this
is the last year I'm going to vote that way.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, Jamie, keep
us posted. Thank you. Thank you so much.
There's Jamie from Canada. He's got his
hands full up there. That's that's clear.